all right so this is a crazy story about
my dad 9/11 happened when I was a senior
in high school old boy Catholic high
school and my mom worked in the World
Trade Center so I don't know what
happened to her I was worried you know
was she okay
I started to cry hysterical because I
thought my mother was dead
this kid Frank starts laughing at me
while I'm crying about my mother so I
broke the chair over his head that was
bad so my teacher was like you gonna get
thrown out of school it's an all-boy
catholic high school that's a rule
you can't break chairs over people's
heads so I called my dad dad yeah I just
got expelled from school
I broke a chair of his own kids head I
was like you live 45 minutes away in
Staten Island there's no way you're
gonna be here in ten minutes 12 minutes
later somehow this guy shows up with the
New York Yankees batting practice Jacket
shorts flip-flops holding a cup of
coffee I was like this is insane so he
walks to the school he's like all right
I need a meeting with the principal you
can't just get a meeting with the
principal he's like get me a meeting
with the principal two minutes later in
the principal's office it's me my dad
brother Rob pieces brother Rob what
happened well your son broke a chair for
someone's head and my dad's like yeah
but he thought his mother was dead the
kid got emotional there's got to be
something we could do I think us what
part of no don't you understand Khan
there's got to be some we could though
we're two grown men are you some kind of
idiot I was like oh that was bad you
shouldn't have said that he goes
Chrissie go stand by the door I was like
what stand in front of the door okay so
my dad says look I'm gonna give you two
options the second one you're really not
gonna like option one we figure out how
to get my kid back in school
diplomatically option two this is gonna
suck for you I come over there break
both your fricking kneecaps no you
didn't think I heard that in a movie I'm
the guy that write the movie about I
don't care I will call the cops right
now tell him where I live what my
birthday is so she Kirby number he goes
because guess what I'd rather go to jail
for the rest of my life than have you
throw my kid out of school and
to listen to his mother's freaky mouth
choice is yours
Chrissy put one minute on the clock what
one minute on the clock do it okay so
we're gonna throw him off the basketball
team no and he'll have detention before
and after class the whole school year
I'm glad we could see eye to eye
wait dad just break his kneecaps I don't
wanna get thrown off the team my dad's
like shut up you almost killed a kid you
gotta pay you know I didn't get expelled
oh and you know my dad and brother Rob
actually became pretty good friends I'm
pretty sure brother Rob works for my dad
I've seen him making deliveries at
sketchy areas of Brooklyn that I know my
dad frequents so yeah that's my dad he's
a great guy and if he kisses you on the
cheek you're probably getting whacked so
sorry
[Music]
you